-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Killer Mike.
I think a lot of Americans
appreciated the importance
of two more Democratic senators
and maybe didn't know the
candidates as much as people.
Certainly this morning,
last night, they got introduced
to Reverend Warnock,
who you knew very well.
He certainly strikes me
as a person we're very lucky
to have representing us
in the Senate.
-I'll tell you one of the most
beautiful things I saw
doing this
was how he approached.
He knew the campaign
was gonna get ugly.
He ran a commercial
with a puppy.
'Cause who can hate a person
holding a puppy?
But more genius, I thought,
in terms of what worked for him
was how the universe works.
I don't belong to any
Abrahamic religion,
but I find myself in churches
like his
more often than people
would think.
There was a commercial
that was ran
that essentially called him
a radical socialist.
And in the description
of who he was, anti-war,
anti-imperialism,
anti-authoritarianism,
I was like, "I wonder whoever
put this hokey commercial
together realized
that they're describing Jesus."
You're describing the messiah
that half of this country
believes in.
And I thought that
it was incredibly God-sent
as a commercial.
Even though it was something
that meant to tear him down,
it really described the Christ
that he serves.
I really believe
that he believes that.
I went to his church,
and I've seen people
see a man of integrity
who lives on that pulpit
like he lives off it.
And I'm very encouraged.
I'm usually not encouraged
to see people from the clergy
take political office,
but I don't think
we're sending a politician
to D.C.
We're sending a public servant,
much like you said,
and I'm very enthused
to see him.
And also Jon.
Jon Ossoff is a young man
of integrity.
I believe that he wants
what's best
for this state and this country.
And he, like Ossoff --
I mean Ossoff, like Warnock,
like John Lewis before them,
are gonna work their butts off,
whether in Congress
or in the Senate,
are gonna work their butts off
to make sure Georgia's
represented well,
Georgians are represented well,
and the United States
is represented.
-We had Stacey Abrams here
a couple weeks ago,
and she was confident.
You know, I will admit,
I think, just based on the last
four years, I maybe
had a cloud of pessimism.
How did you feel on the ground
in the day leading up to it?
-I knew they were gonna win.
And I say that because this
country has shown itself,
thankfully,
because of Donald Trump,
more people voting this time,
showing itself still to be
very in need of healing
and very in need of unification.
And I saw that the votes
that were going for them
were not just votes
for the Democratic Party,
they were not just votes
even for these two candidates,
but they were votes to bring
the union back together,
to bring the healing together,
and hopefully to progress
in a way
that we haven't progressed.
And I'm looking forward
to progressives on the ground
in Georgia, like Mayor Ted,
who just got elected
to DeKalb County's
6th Commission,
making real progress
on the ground.
I'm looking forward to
Fani Willis,
who's our new D.A.
in Fulton County,
making progress on the ground.
I'm looking forward
to people like --
who just got John Lewis's old --
Nikema Williams doing the same.
So I feel that we're gonna be
a more progressive state.
I, again, would just like to say
I really respect our Republican
governor for calling it
like it was, when it was.
He didn't wait,
he didn't fiddle-faddle.
And I want to say that
our two new senators
are gonna do a fantastic job.
And we flipped the state blue.
I want to thank hip-hop
as a culture.
I'm talking about from the clubs
with Blaze and Peaches
to Blue Flame
to the clubs of Compound.
Hip-hop got out,
whether it was artists
or whether it was people
involved in promotions
like Poole or Tracy,
and they made sure our people
got to the polls,
and I want to really respect
the athletic culture here,
via the Atlanta Hawks
and Tony Ressler,
and Steve Koonin
opening up their arena
for people to vote,
and I want to thank hip-hop
for getting out on the streets
and encouraging their fans
to vote.
And thanks, Stacey,
for leading the way, as well.
-It also seemed like the WNBA
had a huge impact
on this election.
-Oh, man.
Oh.
Their owner
ain't hitting on much,
but those girl--
those gals, man,
bless those women's souls.
They rocked it!
They showed
the boss who was boss.
Man, I want to give it up
to our team, man.
The WNBA as a whole,
but God bless us, man.
Those "sheroes" really showed us
what worker solidarity
looks like.
And God bless Loeffler.
You're gonna have
a heck of a time trying to keep
that team under control.
[ Both laugh ]
-So, you know, what is --
We're two weeks out.
And you know, who knows?
Maybe by the end of this show,
it'll actually be
a certified election.
But what is a wish of yours
for the early days of a
Biden-Harris administration?
-My wish is that
it's going to be
around the time
they elected Dr. King's --
the celebration
of Dr. King's birthday.
I challenge everyone
who's watching this
to go watch
"King in the Wilderness"
so you get the chance
to see who Dr. King was
in his last two years of life.
I would like to challenge
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
to watch that, as well,
because I think this country
owes African-Americans a debt.
And it doesn't just mean,
"Hey, I want what's best
and what's right for us."
I'm saying that if our community
is allowed to be as strong
as we can potentially be,
you can have what happened
in Georgia
all throughout the South.
You can have it in Birmingham.
You can have it in Jacksonville.
You can have it in Charlotte.
You can have it in Tampa.
You can have it in North Miami.
You can have it
in Mississippi, Louisiana.
You can have it.
But you have
to play the game fair.
Part of the reason Georgia
was able to flip blue
is because of the cooperation of
the African-American community
and not allowing imaginary
barriers to stop us.
We've all got to want to
work our butt off,
and we worked with allies
and friends and partners.
We can do the same thing, and I
think that's what's possible.
I think that's
what we should aspire to.
And in terms of policy measure,
what I would like to say
from a policy perspective is,
Biden, I would like for you
to take up the challenge I gave
Sanders and he adapted.
Not only allow people
out of jail
for nonviolent drug offenses,
allow them a pathway
into the burgeoning
marijuana market,
so that, unlike when liquor
deprohibated,
a Mafia of sorts happens,
and then you have people
who were exited out
of the business
and weren't allowed to be in it,
in particular,
the Black community,
jazz clubs and owners
and things.
I say now that marijuana's
opening up,
allow us to be in there
with preference,
because we have suffered
under unjust drug laws,
some of which you sponsored.
You know they weren't
good for us now,
so let's make right
and make amends.
I would also ask
that H.R.40 be supported,
which John Conyers
has supported since 1989,
a study into reparations,
because that is old,
and we need to reverse
what years of Jim Crowism did
because this community has only
been free for 57 years.
And beyond that, we need actions
for the working class
in this country.
Working-class Americans need
preference over corporations,
and I challenge
this administration to be that,
for worker-class Americans of
every race, creed, and color.
-Killer Mike,
we've got a minute left.
He was one of my
favorite rappers.
We found out he passed away
two months ago.
Any thoughts you can give us
on MF DOOM?
-Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Make sure
you write it in all caps.
Rest in peace, DOOM, man.
Rest in peace, DOOM.
LP called me and said,
"Get your butt to the lobby
now in the Ace Hotel in
Shoreditch in London."
"Why?"
"Because DOOM is here."
I ran downstairs.
Mos Def was in a bathrobe.
DOOM was there unmasked.
Me and LP got stoned,
drank coffee,
and chilled with DOOM
in the Ace Hotel.
Bucket list!
God bless.
The most amazing concert
is going on in heaven right now,
and I'm slightly sad
I missed it,
but I'm sure I'll see him
in a dream.
Rest in peace.
Thank you, DOOM.
-Thank you for sharing that.
Thank you for being here.
It's always a pleasure.
Killer Mike.